I really need to say a major and huge thank
you to our YouTube subscribers who now number
more than 750,000 this happened yesterday,
so we're just past that number 750,000 now.
And I'm just flattered and so inspired.
When we first started this channel, I think
in the first month we had four subscribers,
maybe it was 10.
I struggle to remember we now are gaining
several hundred subscribers every single day.
And it's extremely exciting as we now get
into an election year, which is often when
growth accelerates and we are really positioned
to get to the next level.
I mean in the YouTube left, thanks to your
support.
And I'm talking about the trolls as well.
I'm thanking the trolls as well and I'll detail
that in a second.
You've got the young Turks with four and a
half million subscribers and then you have
the David Pakman show, Kyle Kalinsky and Sam
Cedar all in the 700 to 800,000 subscriber
range, so this is a great place to be.
It's great company to share and now let me
get to the trolls and the haters.
I have to thank them as well.
The trolls and the haters who make it a point
to dislike my videos and leave a whole bunch
of hate comments on them.
You are actually a huge part of the success
as well.
Individually, the trolls are really annoying.
In total, the trolls represent a portion of
the engagement on the channel that has helped
us grow, dislikes count as engagement.
You see a video and you were motivated to
dislike it.
That means you're engaging with the content,
negative, angry comments.
While many of the comments are vial in their
content, they are engagement and they say
to the YouTube algorithm, wow, the content
here is getting people to take action.
The frequency with which someone is liking
or disliking or leaving a comment, that is
a huge piece of the YouTube algorithm learning
whose videos are likely to generate a reaction
and discussion and keep people watching.
So genuinely thank you not only to the supporters
but to the trolls as well.
All those comments saying, David, you're cha,
you're showing your channel are dying.
Your show is circling the drain by leaving
me those comments and by disliking my videos
you're helping to ensure that it's not the
case and that the show keeps growing.
So extraordinarily exciting year coming up
is my prediction.
As of right now, we are sort of projected
based on current subscriber growth rates to
be close to a million subscribers around election
2020.
Now my hope is that as we really get into
the 2020 election primaries, Trump on hinged,
all of that stuff, I hope that our growth
rate will accelerate slightly and push the
1 million subscriber milestone to before the
2020 election.
It would be amazing.
It is a stretch, but it would be amazing for
us to be a 1 million plus subscriber YouTube
channel, uh, by the time that we'd get to
the 2020 election.
And you know, in the end, the truth is really
what matters is views cause you don't have
to be subscribed to view the content.
Some people often tell me, you know, David,
Dave Rubin's YouTube channel is so much more
successful than yours.
He's got a million subscribers.
We have roughly doubled the views of Dave
Rubin's channel.
Uh, and that is really, um, uh, the, the,
the most important thing.
But there's no question that subscribers are
sort of a very front and center barometer
for how a channel is doing.
So we're going to continue doing our thing.
Seven 50 feels like a great number to be at
this point in time.
I look forward to continuing on in 2020 with
more content, more long form pieces, more
daily political news, interviews and everything
else that's been working for us so far.
Opportunities for you to help.
Do you want to be a moderator of our YouTube
live streams?
We do need help with that because they are
getting so big and out of control that our
current moderators are overwhelmed.
Get in touch via email, through the contact
form on my website.
If you want to be a YouTube moderator, send
a link to your YouTube profile.
Do you want to be a moderator on our subreddit?
The subreddit is now one of the largest subreddits
based around a single show on the progressive
left.
Um, we need more moderators.
We only have I think four and we have nearly
16,000 subscribers on the subreddit.
That is a volunteer opportunity.
Uh, as always, if you want to contribute graphics,
memes, funny things we can use on social media
or whatever the case may be, it is an open
door.
And so much great stuff has come from the
audience.
So I'll met many, many opportunities.
And if nothing else, click the subscribe button
right now.
If you're watching this and you are not one
of our 750,000 subscribers, add your name
to the list.
Click that subscribe button.